hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today i thought that it
would be a very good time for me to try
to
rate my top five games of the console
generation off the bat
we are only doing xbox one and
playstation 4 games we are not going
with pc or nintendo switch for switch
specifically it's because it came out in
an entirely different year
timing it just doesn't make any sense so
what i'm going to do to approach this
is start by looking at other people's
lists and narrow it down
based on the things that exist there
because if look if i were to start this
list okay if i'm gonna do it off the top
of my head
i'm already having a panic attack okay
i'm gonna go god of war i'm gonna go the
witcher 3
i'm gonna go bloodborne i'm gonna go
you know you control these are all
recent though that's the [ __ ] problem
did i write control twice no i really
want control once last of us two i don't
agree
doom 2016 doom 2016 i think i ended up
preferring more than do maternal
is controlling it twice it is okay i
don't think horizons are adored i don't
agree
uncharted 4 i would go uncharted
lost legacy i
wish i could include the legend of zelda
breath of the wild but i can't
cuphead great call detroit become human
bro got it i'm not counting
that injustice 2 i [ __ ] love that
campaign
no arkham knight the best one is arkham
asylum to be clear we're not counting
remakes or remasters because that makes
it way more complicated i already did
re2 but that's that's
sorry i mean that's an entirely
different remake with literally a
different camera control
like that you're right to call me out on
it but it's different
it's so different what do i want to do
with apex legends
this is a good question i'm gonna put
apex on done
okay so then let's go best games
playstation 4.
p5 real well i already put persona 5 but
i guess i can put rail instead
because you know it is the superior game
okay
okay okay done the metacritics top
10 xbox one games ign and see if they
have anything that i've not already
listed
right we got that inside grand theft
auto 5 forza horizon 4
i do love forza horizon but it doesn't
make this kind of list
which are three apex the witness [ __ ]
hell the witness then let's go top ps4
games
ign apex i have yakuza 0 is very good
but it's not quite right for me what's
happened here ign
why have you put dreams as the only one
that's not involved
oh pt absolutely silnet
hill pt i [ __ ] up so bad
no fighting games correct if i were to
do a fighting game
they'd all be old i love all my old
fighting games i don't like any of the
recent ones that much i do like soul
calibur four
and two and marvelous capcom three none
of those count
[ __ ] these are all really good games i'm
not adding any more you guys it's done
it's done this is the shortlist that i
have to make into a shorter list which
is where it gets really difficult
this is gonna suck i'm going to get rid
of control
i don't like the map and i think control
can
uh can be difficult to get into control
is gone
out of worlds and outer wilds i'm gonna
get rid of outer worlds
oh it's already such a good list of
video games oh [ __ ]
okay okay i feel like i have to get rid
of ahri
even though it's currently one of the
main contenders for my game of the year
because it launched so buggy and with
massive frame rate issues
or he's gone dreams
oh i can't do it look okay i'm gonna get
rid of pt
you're right to make it a little bit
easier for myself if i just cut it out
and say it's a playable teaser elana
it's not a video game
oh but i don't want to because it's such
a [ __ ] good video game
i can't no i can't i can't i can't i
can't i'm gonna get rid of outer wilds
oh i didn't like that i didn't like that
okay we're gonna get rid of resident
evil 2 because it is sort of a remake
it's easier for me it's done
cuphead [ __ ]
if i would it consider this god of war
stays
i think these three stay
i think these games i'm i can't see
anyone making any case for me removing
the three of these
right oh god i hate myself
this is the worst thing i've ever done
um
oh my god i'm like actually actively
stressed
until dawn has been one of the most
positive gaming experiences that i have
had
the entire console generation because
and it's
it's circumstantial i played it through
the hallway with my mum
i can't do it yet i can't i can't okay
i'm gonna like italics it okay
i think persona 5 is fantastic i think
persona 5 is is one of the best
jrpgs ever made i think persona 5
systems are super enjoyable the art
style is fantastic i actually think
persona 5 might have the most stylish ui
of any game ever made however
that game's really [ __ ] long and is a
lot of reading text
in a way that i didn't enjoy
i don't want to cut pt because look i
understand what everyone is saying
about pt being a playable teaser
i get it it's a demo it's easy for me to
cut but i
genuinely think pt is the best horror
game ever made
i think the fact that it is a demo or a
teaser
almost helps it and the fact that it
became this like
extremely mysterious
thing oh i'm just at a point now where i
don't know what to do
oh my god i hate this so much okay
okay sorry swiggy steven said it feels
like you're excluding entire genres like
there are no jrpgs or platformers
allowed anymore it's not that they
aren't allowed
like this isn't when you're making a
list of your top five games of the
generation it can't be about like well i
need to make sure i include every
genre right it has to like be just what
games you loved
like you can't it can't be that way um
it is my personal choice and not like uh
let's make sure we have one of every
because that would be way easier frankly
if i could pick one from each genre i
think i have a much easier time
this is not a list of recommendations
this is not
a list that i would give people to be
like here the literal best
it is 100 my personal list
it is not for you if it were for other
people it would be
completely different i have gta 5 on
there but it's not it's my list
these three are in like unquestionably
in my top five games in the gym
they're not going anywhere so really i
have two more spots that i have these
urban dens gone here's the thing if i
get rid of hellblade i also have to get
rid of until dawn because these are the
most subjective games on the list
because they relate to family and that's
why they're on the list
you know what i think that where
hellblade and until dawn are concerned
i can compartmentalize them as being
games that are not necessarily
the best of the generation but are games
that i personally just have an
attachment to regardless of when they
came out
that doesn't count that's what i'm
telling
let myself just drink before i delete
these let me just
i'm gonna finish this
i'm so sorry to both of those games i
it's like i'm killing my children
these six here that
are separate categories i mean you get
rid of red energy too
i know that's a stance i know people
love that game
[ __ ] everyone who's [ __ ] talking
dishonored 2 i will fight you irl
near automatic has one of my favorite
approaches
to storytelling in any video game ever
i'm getting rid of near automotive
because it's ugly in my opinion
this sucks
i didn't like that one i don't i want to
get back
i couldn't do it i couldn't do it
okay if we address them one by one all
right here's what we're gonna [ __ ] do
pros incredible storytelling
best level design in any game
ever
constant
cons of dishonored 2. uh
the levels in between the super dope
levels
are kind of [ __ ]
cons question mark too short
uh ending no makes sense
for the record i've never played pt with
a microphone plugged in
have always managed to finish it who
[ __ ] knows i feel like how strongly i
feel about this means i have to include
pt
which is ridiculous and i know it's
gonna make people mad
i can't get rid of it i only have one
game left that i can add to this
beautiful list of video games
i have to i did it once it has to go
we're not thinking about it nobody
[ __ ] bring it up over again
it nope stop it i'm gonna [ __ ] time
the white out if you [ __ ] in
chat keep mentioning your automotive
i will block the word okay i will
literally block that word you can't
you have to stop i told you to stop
you're being disrespectful
[Laughter]
prose uh beautiful
art style
what's wrong with inside
uh what is wrong with
inside okay the witness
pros uh beautiful
colorful [ __ ]
okay you guys what i've decided here
i'm going to cry before this is done is
that because i'm having so much trouble
with inside and the witness and because
i could
easily point out an issue that i had
with dishonored too
you're right i didn't list cons for the
witness
okay let's do that cons
these are both made up uh these are both
made-up complaints
uh that one puzzle
where you have to stare at the thing
for like 24 hours or whatever
can go [ __ ] itself but it's not inside
oh my god
my top five games of the current console
generation
currently not ordered that's the next
step i stand by it
okay if we're thinking about the list
just broadly right now i think i maybe
want to do this
i think that's maybe step one i think
these two
frankly these three we agreed with from
the start i just had to change some [ __ ]
around
okay okay the issue with the witcher 3
is that it's aged but it's not the
widget 3's fault that it aged
no i think the top three
yeah yep i know what i have to do
and it's this okay it's
the witcher three wild hunt two
god of war three
bloodborne four
inside five
silent hill pt and i don't give a [ __ ]